und dann 80
dann gebe ich jetzt mal wieder den code
ein und jetzt das produkt was ich haben
möchte sagt ausgedacht und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video das ich
hoffe natürlich jedes gut heute ist
total sweater weswegen ich gar nicht
lange hier in dieser langweiligen
wohnung sein möchte wegen raus chempark
kugel sorgen rausgesucht und ja ich
hoffe ihr habt spaß beim anschauen ich
bin echt gespannt wie fans erstmal los
und dann erfahrt ihr mehr weitermachen
ich musste erstmal schnell zur
tankstelle
ich habe einfach nur noch 0 kilometer
restreichweite sieht man dass da kann
man es sehen deswegen tankstelle ist
schon nach vorne
ich glaube das wollten wir hinkriegen
das ist ja auch immer nur so eine
vorsichtsmaßnahme also eigentlich könnte
ich jetzt noch 21 kilometer fahren auch
wenn dadurch stehen aber ist wirklich
nullkommanull egal
leider sorgen kann bei mcdonald's da ja
der mac ist zu hat und nur darauf hoffen
das ist quatsch und verbrannt wird
na ja normalerweise ist es ja nicht
erlaubt oder weiß ich nun auf jeden fall
gab es ja wahrscheinlich schon am titel
gelesen es geht heute mal wieder um
titel bleib nichts wir machen ein paar
wirklich interessant ich habe neue
rausgesucht die man halt auch gut
draußen machen kann und wir fangen an
ihre mit dem ersten mcdonald's und zwar
ist das in amerika voll voll sein trennt
die bestellen da die wollen wir erzählen
die bestellen ein eistee und dann noch
diese milch vom café und haben dann
bubble tea
ich zeige euch jemand das video
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
das so lecker ist aber ich habe das so
oft gesehen deswegen ich stelle mir das
jetzt mal und ich habe eben dazu dann
einen eistee dann war es das
können sie uns vielleicht so kaffee
milch noch dazu geben
jetzt ist also wieder so typisch
naja gut gefahren ich hätte gerne ein
ice t ja das war es eigentlich schon
dankeschön leute beim zweiten mcdonald's
haben jetzt hier bekommen
okay das ist jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen anders aus als in amerika aber
ich habe eigentlich genau die gleichen
zutaten die die rauch haben das wäre
einfach genial wenn das jetzt stehen
beim nicht umfällt wenn das umfeld ist
einfach jedes mal tun die ice rein aus
wenn man es nicht sagt dann tun die kein
schreien aber ist nicht schlimm da ist
als kalt also dass daran sollte es
eigentlich scheitern und wir haben auch
ziemlich viel von dieser kaffee milch
auch ziemlich kleine größe
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt ob man das
feiern kann ich kann mir eigentlich gar
nicht vorstellen warum sollte das denn
so besonders schmecken wenn da so ein
bisschen kaffee mit und so ok manche
feiern einfach münchen also es sieht
schon so ein bisschen aus wie im video
wird und dass man jetzt vor dem mega gut
schmecken na ja das weiß ich noch nicht
ganz
also man schreckt auf jeden fall die
milch die in video hat das so brutal
gefeiert also schmeckt halt in ordnung
aber ich weiß nicht ob sie das solo
enthaltene inhaber nach maß schmecken
und milch ach komm
also muss man nicht bestellen immer an
den nächsten
aber man kann es ja probieren ja die
milch man kostenlos das stimmt ihr könnt
ihr mal ausprobieren und schreibe mir
dann bei den service feiert die hat auf
jeden fall in diesem wie auch gesagt sie
tut das seit dem sie teenagerin ist geht
jemand zu mcdonald's macht diese
kombination super das ist aber ich würde
dass ich das nicht gemacht hat seitdem
ich lebe okay leute kommen wir zum
nächsten mal
ohne scheiß ich habe davon drei videos
gefunden 1 auf polnisch 1 auf deutsch
und 1 auf englisch und die gegend waren
alle kommen und ich habe jetzt natürlich
das deutsche genommen hier will uns
jetzt eine erzählen dass man beim
automaten beim getränkeautomaten so
einen code eingeben kann und dann kann
man sich umsonst was aussuchen
ja ich zeige euch das mal
also ist
einmal und dann 80
dann musst du eigentlich tricks und dann
dieses giften leicht für mehr tricks
also wir können das gerne mal
ausprobieren man hat ja eigentlich sogar
im hintergrund gehört dass er irgendwie
einem ins rennen geworfen wurde aber ich
habe noch andere videos gesehen wo dass
die leute mit anderen kurz und so
gezeigt haben ohne münze die waren dann
besser gefällt wir gehen jetzt zu dem
auto wirklich niemand ist jetzt ziemlich
abgelegen ist und probieren uns mal
meister wir den ganzen körper von diesem
sicherheitsbeamten
also leute wir sind jetzt bei seinem
automaten die haben sogar genau den
gleichen automaten wie im video meiner
meinung nach und für den man hier warten
komme ich nehme sogar auch ein duplo
viele typen video hatte ich noch mal 36
das heißt ohne geld hier zu verwenden
drücke ich jetzt mal hier 36 und jetzt
88 59 sowie der code hier und es tut
sich absolut gar nicht habe ich mir
schon fast gedacht ich zeige euch hier
nochmal kurz ein anderes video und mach
das mal genauso wie der typ da
dann gehe ich jetzt mal wieder den code
ein und jetzt das produkt was ich haben
möchte und das funktioniert wieder sich
ich war ja irgendwie auch klar also das
ist absolut fähig funktioniert überhaupt
nicht habe ich mir schon gedacht ich
verstehe dann einfach nicht wie viele
menschen das leben und vor allem die
vielleicht hat oder willst du was haben
aus dem automaten unwürdig sie kaufen
meldung deute ich mache jetzt selbst
noch mal so ein fake dingen und kostet
das bei mir könnt ihr dann gern
abchecken wie machen wir das am besten
ich steck die karte rein und dann tue
ich so als würde ich so leute musste so
ist nach dem jetzt raus unterwegs waren
auch einen live hecke das haben wir
absolut dumm weise und die konnte man
hier nicht überprüfen ob der wirklich
lieber nicht sind jetzt wieder hier
ich zeige dir jetzt meinen denn wenn
nicht sogar der ich wusste nicht dass
das geht es ist eigentlich schon das ist
echt genial weil ich kenne ich glaube
amazon ist der erste anbieter der das
möglich macht
[Musik]
folglich habe es auch noch nie gesehen
bei amazon wenn du was suchen willst
beispielsweise und was dem wetter hatten
wir den fußball wir haben hier einen
derbystar fußball ist kein placement
hast du schon mal diesen fotoapparat um
in der zelle gesehen ja aber nie benutzt
habt ihr noch nie gesehen und jetzt kann
ich hier so wir drücken jetzt mal hier
auf start
dann wird der ball glaube ich gescannt
ach so und jetzt drückt man hier fußball
unterwegs und da ist direkt der ball
also das ist auf jeden fall was sehr
krasses vor allem für die leute wenn man
sich zb irgendwie ein produkt hat und
nicht weiß was das ist wohl ihr mann mit
notebooks dann kann man es halt einfach
wir haben jetzt den neuen tomb raider
der wir jetzt auch gescannt
da kommen halt nur schuhe rest also also
es ist noch nicht ganz ausgeklügelt sag
ich mal so aber es funktioniert also so
halb ein check machen wir noch und zwar
hier dieser wasserfilter von philips
kalkreiniger was auch immer auf jeden
fall stehen die ganz viele daten drauf
so wie auch auf dem produkt vom video
deswegen checken wir das hier noch mal
kurz ob das muss ja eigentlich
funktionieren ja das ist schon krass
dass es geht also gar nicht beantworten
aber bei den meisten deswegen auf jeden
fall funktioniert
1live geprüft ja leute kommen wir zum
nächsten ecke ich habe mich hier ganz
entspannt mal hingesetzt ich muss sagen
früher einer kindheit jeder hat ja
geliebt und es war damals bei mir auch
schon so es gibt ja irgendwie oder die
werden ja immer so damit er jeden ist
eine bestimmte figur oder so und dann
hab ich jetzt folgendes gefunden das ist
sogar von einem deutschen ja irgendwie
sagen da ist ein punkt drauf auf die
leute weil die letzten tricks gut man
kann sich heute noch mal ein für euch
ich wünschte ich hätte das als kind
gewusst und zwar geht das nur
überraschungseier ist auf jeden fall
darin kleine rapper von büro und die
überraschung die in jedem siebten
überraschungsei drin ist und da gibt es
einen trick die rauszufinden zeige ich
euch das war müsst ihr nur auf diesen
punkt bei dem barcode achten jedes
siebte überraschungsei hat diesen punkt
und normale revanche uns alle nicht
und so findet ihr immer die überraschung
hätte ich dass das kind gewusst das wäre
sogar gewesen ist aber klassen gruppe k
also schnell reden kann er auf jeden
fall
ich komme sagt sie ist diesen kleinen
punkt neben der einst der meint wenn der
punkt darauf ist dass es seit dann ist
das dieses berühmt berüchtigte siebter
aber was ist das besonders drin ja da
ist dann halt einfach diesen
sammelfiguren und das ist ja immer so
sammelfiguren das kleine kind halt
irgendwie ich habe keine lust auf jeden
fall reicht im supermarkt ich habe 50 ua
durch sucht nach diesem zeitpunkt habe
keinen gefunden
das habe ich noch mal sieben hier
mitgenommen um euch das noch mal zu
zeigen so was auf der sagt hier ist
jetzt ein punkt drauf ja hier ist kein
traum
hier ist kein punkt drauf hier ist kein
punkt drauf
er ist auch kein punkt dort ist auch
kein punkt und er ist auch kein punkt
drauf und auf der anderen 50 mal
angeschaut hat war auch kein punkt drauf
das heißt jetzt sehen wir diesen punkt
darauf gemalt irgendwie so macht man
sowas und du wirst jetzt 50 einkünfte
wetter 25 halt also ich dachte so
vielleicht stimmt das ja bild alle hat
mich verarscht man ja weil ich glaube da
muss ich das video hier auch wenn ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen weil die
rocker und auf weitere platz schickt mir
super gerne irgendwas zu was ich testen
soll auf uns nochmal alex wie aber nicht
den kanal und wir sind uns hier
übermorgen wieder gibt's neues video
haut rein aber hin auch meinen zweikanal
alex v da gibt es jeden tag ein video um
das war eine krasse überleitung auf dem
gaming können abonniert alex
okay leute ich zeig euch jetzt wie ihr
kostenlosen drinks aus den automaten
kriegt und zwar wird er den code den ihr
haben wollt zum beispiel hier ich möchte
jetzt red bull
43 und dann wird ihr 8423 was
funktioniert junge leute dafür ein live
mit